hey i heard you went on a date benji
yeah i've gone on i've gone on a couple
dates
aren't you afraid to go on a date during
covert 19
yeah a little bit crazy i guess i don't
know i
it doesn't seem like uh i i'm you know i
take some precautions but what
precaution do you take
i wash my hands i really wash my hands a
lot
i heard you um you the girl met you and
then quickly
left oh i've had
i've had several days and there was one
date recently where uh
this was or a couple weeks ago and where
things weren't up we just went up for a
walk
and then halfway through the walk she
was like well which way are you going to
go now
like how are you oh no she said how are
you going to get home
she goes well i'm going this direction
so i guess you'll be going that
direction wow
how long was the date like five minutes
like that
you know i think she waited it out like
15 minutes or so
oh my god thank god i'm not dating on
apps
he probably doesn't show his body and
stuff and he doesn't present a realistic
picture and then
all of a sudden i know well i'm looking
at benji right now on the camera and you
know he's got his beard
well-shaped you know the facial hair is
in good shape you know and he's got a
hat pulled down
you know over most of his face
that's behind the face in the person
it's with the mask
and if you notice if you just cut him
off at the shoulders
you'd almost think he works out because
he's kind of broad but it's just fat
just look at the hat by the way benji
what's with your beard what color is
that are you coloring your beard
no no no i just put henna in it hannah
is a color ring
no i just did food coloring that's not
coloring so have you gotten laid at all
during coronavirus
no you're not even sure when you get
rejected for a kiss
is it because of corona of course well
there was a good date at the end of it
uh i would lean in for a kiss and i was
gonna take off the mask and she was like
you know signaling not to do that and
then we rubbed our faces against
our mask face against each other like
that sort of that's [ __ ] hot
it was kind of sexy lick my mask
please there was another date where i
went to the girl's apartment and i got i
left
i got lost in her building and there was
some guy started chasing me and i had to
call her
and she she came down and literally had
to like re she got the guy away from me
and like took me to the front of her
building why did a guy chase you
oh he said uh you better call 9-1-1 you
better call he started yelling at me
like probably
we found i i don't understand what
you're talking about i don't know what
you're talking about i got to go
thank you benjamin all right i got to go
color my beard with some feces i'll see
you later